[Music]
oh very good evening you're watching the
press preview it's a first look at what
is on the front pages as they arrive
time to take a first look at the
headlines tonight with the guardian's
chief political correspondent jessica
elgit and the sons political editor
harry cole they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight we'll speak
to them after we've had a look at some
of those front pages starting with the i
which describes the threat to boris
johnson's political future as growing by
the day with speculation mounting that
the number of letters of no confidence
submitted may now be nearing the
threshold to hold a vote on his
leadership
the guardian hears that the prime
minister's shift towards more overtly
right-wing policies in recent days is
what's prompted the back bench unrest
meanwhile the mail leads with concerns
from ministers that the cost of living
crisis has pushed the cost of filling
the average family car with diesel to
more than a hundred pounds
according to the telegraph all but one
police force in the country has missed
its target of answering 90 of 999 calls
within 10 seconds the only force to
succeed by that metric was avon and
somerset
the metro reports on massive airport
cues over the half-term school holidays
delays which are expected to continue
into the jubilee weekend in fact it's
also the lead story in the times which
reports that the government is becoming
increasingly angry with both airports
and airlines
and the ft has a story about u.s
microchip maker qualcomm trying to bake
a state by a stake in its uk rival arm
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching and listening to us and i'm
joined tonight by jessica elgat and
harry cole great to see you both this
monday evening lots to discuss um harry
why don't we start with you uh front
page of the eye tory threat to johnson
growing by the day a steady trickle now
of conservative mps calling publicly for
the prime minister to go or certainly
criticizing uh him how serious has the
situation got
well i think if downing street hoped
that the jubilee
break the half term whatever call it
whitson as they described it in
parliament um is would have taken some
of the sting out of that initial sugree
report drop then i think they've
slightly misjudged the mood because i
think a lot of mps have
gone back to their constituencies um
they've had a look at the lay of the
land they've spoken to their
associations they've probably spoken
some people on the high street as well
and we've had a big debate today whether
the drip drip drip is now indeed a
trickle or a stream um but we have 26 uh
tory mps admittedly out of 354 who are
saying that they'd like a leadership
vote now now that's still some way off
enough to topple the prime minister
and there was a sort of
expectation um that mp's been saying
openly now for many months they'll wait
for two great reports they'll read it
they'll digest it and then make up their
mind now lots of the people who have um
come forward and said the time for
change of leadership are usual suspects
we've seen them before in other
in other leadership coups at the tory
party of the last six years they've
deposed three prime ministers the mark
harpers the steve baker's the andrew
brigians of this world um but i think
what will worry down in street is there
are some sort of middle of the ground um
names on that list sensible former
cabinet ministers have gone you know
what enough is enough now
yeah and jessica it's interesting isn't
it that um when uh there was a vote of
no confidence in in theresa may um only
only half of those letters had been
publicly declared if you like
yes and i think that one of the things
that some tourism told me is they feel
actually very scarred by that experience
of the theresa may um coup where a lot
of it was was was very public there were
you know lots of journalists hold up
outside meetings of the erg where a lot
of it was coordinated you would see
people uh
brandishing letters in front of cameras
and you know people i know who who've
been considering putting a letter in
have said that they certainly wouldn't
necessarily go public with it again
having seen that experience of what
happened to theresa may and of course
she won that
vote of no confidence i i think that
that's a slightly different i think that
was a slightly different situation it
was a disagreement about policy rather
than you know the kind of moral
character of the prime minister um and
also there were there was a there was a
big constituency to try and uh uh keep
theresa may in place because they just
really didn't like what the alternative
was and i think you know one of the
things that's really keeping boris
johnson in place and staying the hand of
some letter writers is there is not that
obvious candidate to take his place that
they would feel comfortable with yeah
jessica i'm going to stay with you
because the next story is that is the
guardian the front page um
the guardian is saying the prime
minister's sudden lurch to the right is
fueling anger uh of tory rebels i mean
tell me about that
yes and i think well i think that
there's
there's two things here firstly that um
there was i think has been an attempt to
try and particularly shore up that right
of the party perhaps some of those who
um
had a kind of growing unhappiness about
um that the tax rises that the number 10
the treasury had put in and and also had
a sort of lingering anger about lockdown
and there's been quite a few attempts to
to to to shore up that support including
um you know this new uh
decision to override the parts of the
northern ireland protocol um uh
and reviews of fracking for example
which which some telemps were very noisy
about um and now there's lots of other
promises including this return to
imperial measurements some hints of the
return of grammar schools and and also
this this this new uh move to to tear up
lots more of eu regulation and and some
of that i think is probably you know
sort of
maybe given some pause for thought um
because they you know they were
grumbling that you know they didn't
really think it was a conservative
government still um but i think you know
amongst the kind of more
veteran tories perhaps ex-cabinet
ministers that the sort of centrist wing
if there are any cameroons left you know
that wing of a party and you know just
it feels it feels to them and they say
repeatedly like it's a government kind
of out of ideas i mean if if what we're
talking about really is the return of
the imperial measurements and that
really spooks some tory mps i mean we've
even got you know some some cabinet
sources quoted in in this piece he said
you know well absolutely bananas yeah
okay i want to get harry's thoughts on
that very quickly and then i'll i'll ask
you uh what the whips are doing to uh to
prepare for a possible uh uh reaching of
the 54-letter threshold
yeah i mean look it's going to take more
than um pint glasses and weights and
measures in fact we've got some detail
on what they're actually going to be
doing and beyond that i think the little
jubilee um announcement that was trailed
into the sunday landed fairly badly
actually and actually i think it's a
fairly minor part of some of the
regulations that we're going to be
seeing in the coming weeks and months um
from uh from from a brexit perspective
there it feels to me like the prime
minister and the chancellor are gearing
up to pronounce a pretty significant
deregulation in the city that would
allow insurance firms um to essentially
abandon quite strict eu rules that um
restrict the amount of the amount they
can invest um insurance firms could
invest they have to keep a certain
amount of capital in their um in their
accounts and that's all going to go on a
bonfire um i suspect in the coming weeks
big speech on the economy which i think
will see the bizarre spectacle of the of
the chancellor and the prime ministers
giving a joint speech um about the sort
of next big bang for the city so that
could actually be
proper red meat um for brexiteers proper
red meat for the um
for the party and probably red meat for
the country that will make pint glasses
look a little bit a little bit silly
okay and harry front page of the
telegraph um uh the wits uh the whips uh
plot a lobbying drive um
should these 54 letters go in
yeah i mean whips are always going to do
whipping stuff you know
number 10 are quite bullish still the
government are quite bullish still that
if it does get to the 1a um does get to
the the 54 letters they will win that
180 that's required the 50 of the party
plus one boris johnson's not a man
that's going to go just because he feels
you know you know he's lost a certain
amount of of face should we say if he
died i think he would have gone a while
ago if that was the case but it is a
numbers game and at the moment the the
the government payroll is so big up to
about 173 i by my account of the
associated ministers bag carriers now
look some of them will vote against the
government but there's still a healthy
50 i'd say tory back benches who support
the prime ministers so the odds are
still in prime minister's favor tonight
um that he would win that confidence
vote okay uh jessica still i mean there
are other hurdles to go aren't there in
this talk that some mps may be waiting
till after the bank holiday weekend
after the jubilee weekend to uh to put
their letters in we've got the
parliamentary inquiry as well plus we've
got two by-elections um so you know
that the prime minister has got a lot to
be stressed about
yes and of course there are always going
to be those mps who um always decide to
put off the decision and you know
there's i think that there's you know
people who've said that they now you
know have to wait until the end of the
privileges inquiry because the thing
that matters most to them is whether the
prime minister has lied to parliament or
not um and and others you know just
brutally speaking want to take a more
you know look at the electoral picture
and
and and see what happens in wakefield
and see what happens in tibetan where
you know labour and the domes could win
respectively and i suspect you know
for many of them that will be what the
threat they see to their patch the most
do they see it as labor you know
regaining parts of the red wall or do
they see it as the lib dem regaining
parts of the southwest and uh
or winning new ones and i think the
thing for those mps who are worried
about the lib dems is that boris johnson
is really potentially the factor that's
that's giving the lib dems hope uh maybe
wouldn't be the same under a different
prime minister so i think that that's
that's one of the things that's really
you know maybe convincing some of the
some of the letter writers okay we'll
take a pause uh they're coming up after
the break could we soon be paying a
hundred pounds to fill up our cars we'll
be discussing that and more next
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview harry and jessica still with us
uh front of the daily mail jessica um i
think we're all noticing this aren't we
as motorists um
diesel now at one pound 82 a liter
petrol at one pound 72 the male saying
save us from the 100 pound tank of fuel
yes and the and then this story is
essentially calling on ministers to to
further cut those fuel taxes even after
the you know the cut that we saw earlier
in the year and meaning that you know
and the average is saying that average
monthly fuel bills have gone up by at
least 56 pounds a month which is you
know a huge amount for people on low
incomes and often you know people people
who are relying on their cars or vans to
get to work in particular diesel is
particularly something that will affect
uh van drivers and and you know i think
one of the things that you know bigger
picture that this shows is we know we
saw an enormous cost of living package
from the chancellor last week and yet
there are still places where you know
consumers still aren't really being
shielded by the effects of huge soaring
fuel prices and it just shows how the
government is struggling to keep
people's heads above water
yeah harry it also says here uh that the
wholesale price of diesel is cheaper
than the wholesale price of petrol
um and yet diesel is more expensive at
the pump than petrol and they're sort of
accusing um uh service stations of
ripping off the motorist is that fair
heaven forbid um yeah yeah it's totally
fair um
the obviously the chance to cut fuel
duty at his spring statement one of the
one of the few things he got right i
think in that spring statement much of
which he's had to return to in his mini
emergency budget whatever you wanted to
call it last week um however it's it is
being gobbled up by the by many not all
supermarkets and petrol providers
um because it's just not being passed on
now we've heard lots of warm words from
the government
um
saying you know it's time to pass it on
i think they're gonna have to step in
and act you know we can only write so
many letters before you start looking a
little bit impotent so something really
does need to be done there and
don't forget the more expensive the
petrol gets the more the treasury is
actually taking on bat because vat is
charged at a flat rate and therefore the
price goes up they're going to get more
money for it so it's all very well
making lots of noise and telling um
telling uh telling petrol providers to
to cut their costs the treasury laughing
all the way to bank on this one yeah and
uh finally let's finish with the front
of the metro if people are deciding to
leave their cars at home
and head uh head off to sunnier climbs
it's miserable there as well jessica um
i mean that that the the images we've
been seeing from airports over the last
few days have been so depressing
yeah and astonishing and also one of the
saddest things about it is that this is
the first half term or maybe the first
holiday that a lot of people are going
to have in in in many you know in in two
years um in most and that's one of the
things obviously that's fueling this
chaotic scenes at the airport lots of
people have got vouchers to use loads of
people have you know been saving up
through very difficult times through the
pandemic to go on their first holiday in
years and they find themselves you know
waiting for eight hours in a boiling hot
airport um you know at the start of
their half-term break and you know it is
it was some of it's a repeat of the
scenes that we saw in manchester airport
were
earlier in spring where it was just you
know complete chaos with with no staff
available and record vacancies although
they seem to advanced airports still
seem to be um advertising rather low
salaries for their bus drivers but but
you know there is there is a chronic
shortage of staff you know across the
the industry and um it's it's very uh
you know if i'm with the government i'd
be very worried about what
with coupled with the passport crisis
and passport way i'd be very worried
about what some holidays are going to
look like
yeah harry just a 10-second thought on
this
yeah it's an industry that went to the
wall in the pandemic um literally and
you know you can't turn the engine on
and expect it to leak back into life
automatically but it does feel to me
like perhaps they can pull their finger
out a little bit